using hand
sanitizer is a new way of life for
everyone
hand hygiene is recognized and promoted
as the single most effective measure to
reduce the spread of coronavirus
[Music]
and this is what the world health
organization
says we should all use so we've got
absolute alcohol
hand sanitizer containing at least 60
percent alcohol
it kills the virus in 30 seconds if you
have something that has a fatty membrane
around it
the alcohol will destroy that membrane
and therefore destroy
the microorganism that you're looking
for and coronavirus does have one of
those it's called its envelope
and that's what alcohol does it kills
that envelope off and then therefore
kills the virus
but sky news has established hand
sanitizer containing
no alcohol is being sold and used across
the uk
so much of it that scotland's first
minister was filmed in a school
using hand sanitizer that doesn't meet
her own government's requirements
this factory in oxfordshire is making 75
000 liters of alcohol-free hand
sanitizer
every month entirely legally to a
european
and british standard the standard tests
it
not on hands but in a test tube this
sanitizer takes
two minutes to kill coronavirus we have
tried to follow as much of the
regulations that are available to us
the british standards that we follow we
provided the schools with the relevant
information
it has been tested to kill coronavirus
it's safe it's soft on hands it's good
for the children there's many benefits
there for them
and i think the main thing is it works
it's in
your interest on march the 3rd the
health secretary was clear
this is a national effort we need
everyone to listen to
and act on the official medical advice
at that time the official advice was use
60 alcohol the next day mr hancock said
the government was making sure the
public knows
exactly what they should be doing to
keep themselves
and others safe but on the 13th of march
the commitment to alcohol-based
sanitizer
was quietly withdrawn and now there is
no recommendation
at all a leading expert says that is
wrong
no i am concerned because when we uh we
we know we've got an effective product
in alcohol hand sanitizers 60 percent or
over 62 percent
or above i don't see why we should be
prepared to
to to settle for something which has not
been
tested under use conditions and i think
that that is a failing in response
the british standards institute told us
in a statement
if the product meets the requirements of
outcome of the
test methodology a product is deemed
to pass this enables different types of
products
to be used safely westlothian council
says its schools are no longer using
alcohol-free products in key areas
it said we use both alcohol and
non-alcohol-based products
we have adhered to the scottish
government's guidance
we asked the department for health and
social care for a response
but they have not provided one
there are now hundreds of thousands of
bottles
of alcohol-free hand sanitizer being
used
across the country the watering down of
advice from westminster
has left people unsure what they're
using
or how long it takes to kill coronavirus
on their hands gerard tub sky news